the time to really sort of mind the
wisdom on the stage here so Andy your
mom showed sort of meditation to you
when you were younger like 10 or 11
years old how did that still inspire
your journey to becoming later on become
a monk sort of a decade later in
spending the journey traveling the world
share a little bit of that with us given
it's a very unconventional path to
running one of the best startups
hey I'm very good afternoon everybody it
is in his a has a long story to fit into
just a few sentences but um he I learned
I learned meditation was about 11 years
old with my mom very progressive kind of
mom and bit of a hippie and um and it
wasn't until really kind of my late
teens that I found it I really
understood how valuable and useful it
could be I think when I was younger so
it was a nice thing to do it's quite
relaxing I think it was only later on
when my mind started to get really busy
and my you know emotions started to
overwhelm me a little bit more that I
really understood kind of how powerful
it could be and yeah it was you know he
was a couple of couple of really
difficult sort of situations events
unfolding the friends family that I lost
in my my late teenage years there really
kind of spurred me on to think okay I
want to understand the mind not from a
text book not from other people's
opinions but really to kind of look at
the mind and understand it and that's
what drove me to quit my university
degree and go away and become a monk
yeah pretty wild how do you guys you
guys like is this voice or how many of
you guys use headspace I know it's dark
out there
recognises crazy voice thank you for
using his place guys this is what he
looks like right here
so I think it also really began when you
ran into this person here mr. rich so
when you guys met each other you were an
ad agency exec how did it
what was that sort of meeting like and
the subsequent meetings how did this all
come about in terms of you guys deciding
what you wanted to solve hi Ron um yeah
so we got introduced by a mutual friend
and I been working in advertising agency
I said and I'd burn out pretty bad and
it was in a really not in a good spot
would be fair to say and my friend said
you should go me Andy's he's been
teaching me meditation and my friend was
like the last person that I ever thought
would be meditation so that in itself
was kind of surprising and he said yeah
he used to be a Buddhist monk and he's
got a clinic in in London teaching
people one-on-one so they all sounded
very normal and and we met each other
and I think we kind of we both got on
immediately and I started practicing
meditation we did a bit of a skill swap
and into a meditation I came up with a
few ideas for his clinic and it was very
organic I would go over the road there
was a coffee shop over the road and we'd
spend an hour together and we just chat
and about six months you know about six
months went by and we kind of both
decided that you know actually that we
should try and do this and and his pitch
to me was like I can't afford to pay you
but you want to come and work you want
to come and do this and that remained I
pitched to all the people we took on for
a long period of time as well thankfully
they came anyway yes right so when you
said we're gonna do this what is this
how did it start
well the original I think the original
idea that we talked about was like how
could we create the kind of Nike+ of
meditation that was the original kind of
brief I thought was an interesting
parallel that they'd taken running which
have been seen as a kind of boring
pursuit and they'd made it
social they've made it engaging they
made it fun again and we kind of felt
that you know meditation there was
something in that but I'd let you tell
the story
out the the digital thing versus the
event piece yeah so which has some fun
with this you know as you can imagine
coming out of a monastery I didn't know
a lot about technology truth is I didn't
really know much about anything other
than meditation and you had a sit
quietly with my eyes closed
ah which is an entrepreneur I personally
I still think it's quite a valuable
skill but you know which was less sure
and we were talking about kind of how to
scale it in which was telling me about
this this this Nike blast thing you know
and I had no idea what he was talking
about and I'm not even sure I had a
mobile phone at the time I was a very
late adopter and and so it for me like
I'd only I'd come from a lineage in a
tradition where it was always handed
down sort of person to person so I
couldn't imagine it another way you know
so I said okay well instead of doing
that why don't we do events and we
actually ran you know we ran events for
probably two years before we even
considered making an app so we you know
I know the the theme of the the
conference is hassle we really it really
felt like for the first two or three
years that's all we did was hustle and
we were hustling to get people to event
and we were hustling to get meetings we
were saying yes to anybody that would
offer us a meeting or an audience and
not laugh at us for what we were trying
to do and we you know we really that was
a massive part of how the app you know
came came to be so it seems like like
many entrepreneurs and many under the
audience of it was a period of
experiment experimentation a period of
ramen noodles and not making a lot of
money from the events there was a point
in time where it kind of took off tell
us what that point was and how did you
arrive at that point well I think it I'm
not sure whether yeah there was
definitely a point when I think we kind
of felt that it changed we we were down
to our last like 50,000 bucks and the
events although they were fantastic
because they were kind of an amazing
chance to see people face-to-face and
talk about
what they wanted and I think that
affected the product that you kind of
see today and the one that was before
that but basically we want to do an
event in New York and we'd met someone
they said have you ever thought about
doing this is a subscription and the
business wasn't working no one was going
to give us any more money and so we had
50,000 bucks left and we beg stilled and
borrowed basically to get that thing
made all the animations got done for
free all of the audience they saw we're
friends and family really but all the
audio got recorded for free well the
video got recorded for free the agency
that built the the website and the app
did an 80% reduction just because they
kind of believed in kind of what we were
doing and then we convinced the Guardian
which is a big paper in the UK to put a
million booklets on the front of every
single Guardian newspaper and it had an
offer for the subscription and in that
first month that we launched in January
you know we took I never remember I
never forget I was watching the money
kind of come in like by the hour I kept
refreshing it going oh my god we've got
a business that actually works and we
took thirty six thousand pounds in that
first January to put that in perspective
that is about as much money as we made
in the previous 18 months so I think at
that point we thought there's something
there's something in this from a
business point of view and that could
work there's a great lessons for true
bootstrapping
so going from with less than $50,000
cash in it back to 40 million dollars
recently raised both of you are
non-technical founders a how did that
happen like how did you accomplish that
I have no idea still to this day you
know I'm gonna try and answer that I do
a lot of lepre I'll let rich answer it
you know from a technical point of view
or you know like how how it's actually
happened but I do believe that if you
have a passion but we never set out with
the idea of like let's make a billion
dollar company you know that wasn't kind
of what we were saying out to do we set
out because we believed in something and
we had a passion about something we knew
that it had the potential to be
commercially sustainable Andy
been successful but that's not what we
were kind of doing and why we were doing
it and I still believe now that if you
set out with that in mind and you
there's no fear because what have you
got to lose there is nothing to lose so
I feel like we've always kind of worked
in that way and believed that anything
is possible and I think still to this
day both of us we are naively optimistic
and we really do kind of live day-to-day
as though anything is possible and when
you live like that there is at least the
opportunity or possibility for anything
to happen I'd say the other thing is
that the support around the mission and
kind of what we try to do the people
have been willing to help either your
classic kind of case in point I think
people have really rallied behind what
we've been doing because they believe in
what it's actually putting out in the
world and I think that has that's made a
huge difference like the amount of help
that people gave us in those early days
especially not just were giving us stuff
for free but their time and their
contacts and you've got to meet this
person and like when Andy got his TED
talk that was you know really driven by
you know a friend that really kind of
pushed for that to happen in it and it
did and it was a big thing for us at
that time that was a huge huge deal so
and I could list millions of things but
I do think that that has really kind of
helped propel it more than more than
normal and I think the the other bit and
all of you guys will relate to this I'm
sure is recognizing what our strengths
are and also I lack of in many different
areas and so finding the right people
you know just as from the very beginning
we didn't want to do everything
ourselves and we knew we couldn't do
everything ourselves
so really working hard to bring in the
right people who could do the job much
better than we ever could dream of doing
you know and and it's a it's a team
thing you know it's nice that people
come up and say hey I love headspace
well done and congratulations it's not
us you know there's a team of 100 people
kind of doing this you know and it's
growing every week and so it's the team
that kind of make it happen you two are
always always a super humble and I think
element of a little bit of luck in
everybody's life but certainly I don't
think you guys arrived here accidentally
and it's not what you guys are saying
but in terms of thinking of the scale
you're at today over seven million users
almost 200 countries and it's wonderful
in the backstage to see all these folks
walking up and say hey oh my god it's
you guys it's your voice it's it's quite
an amazing accomplishment talk to folks
out here who are just getting started
who are working with hustling who are
trying to bootstrap give them some
nuggets of how did you what are some
things that you would say I mean you
guys never had a big team never hired
people before never led a big project
give us some things on how we got here I
mean personally I'd say look go off to
the Himalayas shave your head become
among a nun for ten years it's easy um
no I look I think there are so many
different ways to this but I would say
I'm gonna do kind of maybe the clarity
element unless you really kind of a
clear unless you know what it is you
want to achieve and where you want to
get to it's highly unlikely you're going
to get there you know same for all of us
and and I do think so often we start
with an idea but and the idea is great
but the idea is also very vague and we
kind of we set out on this journey and
unless it's really of course you want to
be open and open to possibilities along
the way but we kind of really need to
know where we're heading for whether
it's in six months one year three years
five years and I really believe kind of
in if you refine that from the very
beginning of course is going to change
along the way it sounds obvious you know
but for me it's something I've had to
learn as we've gone along the way you
know we started off with a very general
idea but we've had to really refine that
destination again and again and again
and it's still being refined but unless
that's clear in the mind then I think
it's really difficult to put it off and
yeah I think that piece around passion
like fast the you know both personally
this is it doesn't really feel like a
job because
the meditation bit is the thing that
we're most passionate about you know
inside of work and outside of work so it
doesn't ever feel like work and I know
that I've we're really lucky that we
have that and we talk about that a lot I
do think there's a lot of frivolous
stuff that gets made in the world not
just in tech just generally and I think
there's some amazing stuff that is
trying to you know deal with really big
issues that need to be fixed and solved
by really smart people like yourselves
and I think trying to match that kind of
passion with kind of something that's
going to have genuine impact and I do
think that there's so many areas that
need the need help that for me feels
like something because it's so hard
doing this every day and keep doing it I
do think you have to have that to keep
that kind of hunger and passion going
otherwise I think it's really really
difficult we were talking about life we
were selling widgets I'm not sure that
we'd be we'd be very successful because
we're terrible at selling widgets in
terms of just along the way in that
you've been around for about six years
your business are there specific people
books resources that you've lied on for
both education on how to be a leader how
to be a founder or just for inspiration
are the things that you guys lean on
yeah I mean I don't know if I can talk
for both of us I think I probably can we
the truth is we probably should read a
lot more about what just generally but a
lot more about entrepreneurship and
about leadership and all of those things
are we don't our which is definitely
better at it than than I am we both take
our our inspiration from books about
great meditation masters and it might
sound strange and you might kind of
think well what's the relevance you know
but actually so much of not only
understanding kind of where we want to
go is understanding our own mind but so
much of understanding our own mind helps
us understand the minds of others and
when you're trying to build an
organization and when you're trying to
kind of create a culture hopefully of
kindness and creativity and authenticity
which for us or the
the three kind of key key parts of that
team and it becomes really relevant to
what's going on in in your mind and I
really feel like read those stories you
know and reflect on those ideas for both
of us we try and bring those into the
workplace every single day they might
feel at first when you read them a bit
so esoteric and a bit kind of you know
they belong somewhere else in another
part of the world but actually if you if
you really take them and you spend time
to understand them they're incredibly
relevant and incredibly useful so I
don't know if it's appropriate or not
but there's just a couple you know that
I really would recommend regardless even
if you're not interested in meditation
and that kind of thing there's one
called Zen mind beginner's mind by a
Japanese Zen monk called Suzuki Roshi
the guy was a genius and he basically
introduced meditation to the West in the
way that we know it now and in fact he
was he was local he was up in San Fran
and I think he made a massive impact and
if ever your mind feels really kind of
busy and you're just too caught up in
thinking that's a great book to read
where he just helps you kind of zoom out
and you just get a very different
perspective on your own mind and on
whatever's going on around you and the
other one is um it's a little more
challenging but it's called cutting
through spiritual materialism and I
think it's brilliant for a Western
audience and it's by a Tibetan teacher
and he just blows away all the myths
that we might have around kind of
meditation and spirituality and all
these things and it just says how is it
relevant to what's going on in your life
right now
and I think for entrepreneurs it's a
it's a really useful book it's great to
hear about you rich anything you know I
as Annie says these are the books that
we kind of talk about and discuss a lot
and I think when when Andy first taught
me meditation these were the places that
he directed me and at first I found them
they were quite quite difficult first
the kind of to kind of understand some
the language and did it make sense but
you know one of those books in
particular I've just I've reread maybe
20 32
it's like I read it a chapter out of it
every single morning before I practice
and it's been a huge huge help to me not
just in work in everything and I think
that's that's the type of inspiration
it's a type of stuff that we try and
tell the team to kind of look at so it's
not so traditional but it's for us I
think is it's really important I just
seen the so often like we we tend to
separate our work life and our and our
personal life when we think okay what do
we need to read for work and what do we
need to read like I don't know how you
guys but I the mind that I have at home
I take into work and the mind that I
have at work I take home in the evening
you know and mine is not separate you
know and the work we do on it and then
we when we train our mind you know we do
it at home we're also kind of impacting
our mind at work and vice versa so I
think is whatever kind of helped you
find that sense of of calm and clarity
and contentment and for us is it's those
kind of books I mean I guess you guys
can see very clearly that these guys
really live sort of what they teach and
I think as an investor myself as I look
at startups and founders this is the
trade I'm looking for this is what you
can't this is the story you can't fake
right like these guys are deep in it it
comes from really deep inside it's very
clear I mean you can see it very clearly
up here I was just amazing to see one
more question before we jump into the
audience you've been doing this for six
years a lot of people would say you've
made it I guess you could argue whether
that's true or not but as we know as
businesses grow the intensity in general
increases the challenges may change but
it's fairly challenging you work very
long hours and we were having dinner
last night talking about this like do
you ever take a break for yourself and
if you do how how do you relax how do
you reward yourself for quote unquote
success if you want to call it that um
well surfing has been thinking that as
as going to save me on it on a number of
occasions and we take regular surf trips
together
in fact when we're kind of struggling
with a big problem at work we often go
away and kind of do
retreat based around surfing so that
that has been a huge thing for me and
just just generally getting out in
nature and getting away from the normal
routine that you find yourself in I find
kind of frees something up this it's
pretty simple I lead a pretty boring
life is the truth but it kind of works
that's the simple things that I add
around my work that kind of make it
manageable I think super cool it's great
that you share and your outside life you
share very similar interests so there is
a nice merging if you want to call it or
the for sure I get to just to be clear I
now we have a child I get to do a little
less surfing these days who these surf
trips do exist but they're not as
frequent my wife used to be very
enthusiastic about me going away now a
little less oh so yeah I totally
understand I know where we are maybe out
of time but I wanted to I know you guys
probably have a lot of questions in the
audience is very dark I'm not sure how
we want to run this but I want to have
some questions out there over this way
guys Andy rich saying so I'll be brief
hopefully I backstage I can tell you I
came out here from Orlando Florida tell
you thank you
one year ago my father had a bypass
surgery on his heart and his life was at
risk he very much like me was always
getting upset very tense very stressful
of course as a surgeon and the first
time in our lives we did a father-son
goal and the last 125 days we've been
meditating together across the country
through your app and it saved my
father's life and my life as well and I
wanted to just personally thank you and
hopefully shake your hand to say thank
you for changing my life
one
one quick note - what Andy Dunn said
about self-awareness it's very important
and yeah I I forget what you say every
day but I never forget the way you guys
make me feel the way I feel then today
when I do your practice so thank you
somebody's sharing thank thank you
good afternoon rich and Andy my name is
a beer
you know the cultures of mindfulness and
cultures of Commerce can be at odds with
each other at times I was wondering if
you had any experience you can share
where you really helped define a culture
at headspace that honors both of these
Heritage's which you've integrated what
is a few things I think one it's it's
about how can we encourage practice
without forcing practice I think that's
the key to getting that kind of cultural
bit right internally so 10 o'clock every
morning you know kind of large group
space we do it at 8:10 we do it together
again at 3 o'clock in the afternoon we
do that and then we've got these
meditation pods that we've got there
that anyone can use any time in during
the day and it's all optional and I
think that helps to set a kind of
culture like if we can get people kind
of taking time out and actually
practicing the content I think it has a
huge impact in how people are in their
day and and how they kind of respond to
one another I think at the same time our
mission is to improve the health and
happening to the world which is big and
I'm not sure it will ever be finished
which is kind of part the reason why we
like it but it's also means that that's
going to take resources and we need to
be able to build a successful business
so we can attract the best talent and I
think I think it's I to be honest with
you something that we kind of it's a
really it's a point of tension that we
that we're constantly kind of working at
and I'm not sure that we've got it
perfect would you say absolutely I think
one of the the biggest things for us
that we landed on probably few years ago
we actually started out kind of thinking
it's going to be a charity and we kind
of worked at how to make it a little
more quick-moving than a charity but we
started a study something called get
some give some couple of years ago which
means that we we were able to balance
that
kind of commercial with also that the
culture of mindfulness actually making
it more available to other so every time
someone buys a subscription we're able
to to give one away to someone who
otherwise wouldn't be able to afford it
or have access to it so it's but as rich
that it's a constant balance trying to
find that sweet spot
I think hi I'm Chris and first I really
wanted to say thanks to you and your
team because after hundreds of
mindfulness sessions through headspace
it's helped me in my mental health as
well as inspired the product I'm trying
to build and one thing I see though is I
recommend it to a lot of hustlers you
know oh you're feeling kind of stressed
well you definitely you got a lot on
your mind you could use some headspace
but I still see a lot of people who have
a really hard time especially with the
hustler mindset of integrating
mindfulness into their daily practice so
have you found any things that could
help all of us you know do that a little
better
sure yeah it's one thanks for using
headspace and I'm really happy it's had
that impact for you I in terms of
integrating into your everyday life I
like building any routine our same time
same place is really helpful if you can
do the first thing in the morning before
the day's really got up and running if
you can do it even before you check your
emails and know it's a big ask but if
you can it's ten minutes I think that
will make a make a massive difference
try tying it to something else so it's
called coupling and it's when you you
might have a shower and then meditate or
you have a cup of tea and then meditate
or breakfast to meditate so something
that you already do on a daily basis you
just simply add meditation to it and
because it's already part of your
routine you're that much more likely to
do it I think the biggest kind of often
for many people you know it is a time
thing and I don't have an extra 10 15
minutes to spare in a day I'm very busy
and maybe it feels as though that's
wasted times those unproductive time as
though you're not doing something
valuable towards achieving your goal but
the truth is actually the other way
around as a result of taking that time
out
you will be clearer you will be more
focused you will be more productive
you'll probably achieve way more in the
day than you otherwise would have done
yeah thanks so much no worries all the
time we have thank you guys so much a
thank you